&gt;&gt; This is very exciting, Lauren. Now, before we go to the next event, Susan said
that this was an absolute threshold test. Does that have anything to do with
the difference threshold test we saw earlier?
&gt;&gt; That's a good question, Andy. It's related. Do you remember with the difference
threshold, we were looking at how much stimulus needed to change in order to
detect it.
&gt;&gt; Right. The contestants could detect a difference between like 100 and 105
grams. But not necessarily 100 and 101.
&gt;&gt; Exactly. Well, with an absolute threashhold, we're looking to see how much of
the stimulus is needed to be detected at all.
&gt;&gt; Okay, I think I see. So, we're answering different questions. For example,
what's the quietest sound that a human can hear.
&gt;&gt; Exactly. In this event we're measuring pitch. We want to see what the highest
pitch a human can hear is. We're looking at the limits of human perception.
&gt;&gt; That's really exciting. Now, oh, it looks like they've actually already begun.
Let's go to the event.